airline shares have been hammered since
the start of the crisis many companies
are struggling for their very survival
but those same shares have soared this
week on hopes of a recovery American
Airlines is up some 60% on the week
while International Airlines group which
owns ba was up 25% by this morning and
as you can see it is up further today
that's on hopes of air corridors across
Europe by AG shares some 12% to the good
right now alive now to British Airways
headquarters in West London where I can
speak exclusively to I AG's chief
executive Willie Walsh Willie welcome to
you you coming 12,000 jobs that seems
rather extreme well in what we're doing
is we're consulting with the trade
unions with the elected representatives
on potential job cuts no decision has
been taken in relation to actual
redundancies but what we have done is in
compliance with the law and it's
important to state this there is a legal
obligation on the company to submit
these documents to the elected
representatives and then engage in
consultations to give everybody an
opportunity to try and reduce to
mitigate to do anything we can to reduce
the impact of the potential
restructuring on the business that is
what we're doing at British Airways and
that is why we want the trade unions to
engage with the British Airways
management team to represent the people
that are working hard in British Airways
to ensure that the airline can have a
future
well the unions say that it's not
necessary to negotiate under these
section 188 redundancy notices they say
for example that Ryanair and easyJet
haven't had to resort to that well we
would disagree and in fact there's
plenty of legal precedence where trade
unions have sued and successfully sued
companies who have engaged in
discussions without submitting these 188
10 letters and in fact British Airways
was one of those companies sued by
United in the past and if you look like
this very recent case with monarch
Airlines who were sued by unite for not
going through the formal process so
we're acting under legal advice
having compliance with the law
and that's what we intend to do so you
know this is a really stressful time for
everybody but I think you've got to
realize and I'm sure people do we're not
flying last month
in in May we flew a total of four
hundred four hundred and eighty five
passenger flights 485 in a month we did
not buy lunch time on the 1st of May
last year so this is the most difficult
challenge the airline industry has ever
been faced it's unprecedented and we
need to take action to ensure that all
of the airlines in the book and
everybody in the industry is taking
action to ensure that we can survive
this and to ensure that we have a
competitive business for the future why
is the axe falling at British Airways
the most profitable part of IAG rather
than at other parts of the group well
what that is just untrue in all of the
airlines in the group and as you know
you mentioned it yourself Airlines
globally are pursuing restructuring you
know the focus here is on British
Airways because we're in the United
Kingdom but I can assure you that all of
the airlines in IAG face the same
challenge and the management teams at
all of the airlines are pursuing the
very same issues the scale of the change
is pretty similar for all of the
airlines and the measures that will be
taken I believe are going to be similar
but these are individual companies the
responsibility at British Airways is for
the management team at being at Iberia
will be the Iberia management team in
the same ways in Ireland it will be
their Lingus management team so it's
untrue to say that British Airways is
the only company in the group looking at
restructuring I can assure you all of
the airlines of the group are doing so
what about this allegation from the
Union of thuggish behavior that we heard
from Len McCluskey this notion that
you're going to make staff redundant and
then rehire them on lower salaries again
in I have to stress what we have done in
compliance with the law is to set out
proposals that we want to consult on
it's for the trade union to engage to do
the responsible thing to represent their
members who are crying
for the Union to do so to sit down with
the management team to try and come up
with solutions that is the responsible
thing to do it is by no means a exercise
that we enjoy doing I want to do it's an
exercise that we have to do we are
facing the greatest crisis the industry
has ever seen and we need to respond and
that means every management team has to
do what's right for the airlines that
they manage but some members the cabin
crew told us that they're facing pay
cuts of 70% I mean that seems pretty
severe I can tell you that the proposals
have been put forward with a view to
consultation we have not taken any
decision it would be irresponsible for
us to make these decisions without
giving people the opportunity to sit
down with us in consultation and come
forward with alternatives to what it is
we are looking to do now that's exactly
what the law requires us to do that is
exactly what we are committed to doing
and I can assure you the British Airways
management team have made themselves
available now for over 160 different
meetings with the trade union
representatives to try and progress this
issue I'm pleased to say we are in
consultation with the pilots union about
those consultations continue the reports
I get it are that some progress has been
made they have not concluded but I would
hope that the trade unions do what the
law requests of them because the
obligation is on us to consult you know
if they don't want to turn up to the
consultation clearly that's the decision
that they would take but I would urge
them to do what is right for the people
in British Airways and to sit down at
the table and engage in these
consultations so that we can together do
what is right I'm not involved in the
consultations it's the responsibility of
the British Airways management team they
are ready willing and able to do this
the problem is really a lot of staff
appear to have lost confidence in the ba
management and would probably rather see
you at the table
I think that's unfair in you know I
think the management team is working
very very hard to do what's right
they've demonstrated in the past that
they can do that British Airways is a
very well-run company the people in be a
from top to bottom right across the
organization are great people they all
work very hard they are all committed to
the success of the airline and I've
absolutely no doubt that everybody our
British Airways even don't stop
recognize that they may not have a
future in the business want to see
British Airways succeed what about this
campaign by unite few Toulouse lots at
Heathrow if you're losing 25 percent of
staff will you need as many slots in
future it's it is a challenge I will be
honest with you but don't forget this is
across the British Airways group so
British Airways as a significant
operation at London City at Gatwick and
at other airports so it's not just about
Heathrow but clearly we would like to
for the future secure all of the slots
that we currently have at Heathrow that
may not be possible it may may require
us to leave some of the slots that we
don't intend to operate but we would
like to see given that slots at Heathrow
tend to be at a premium we would like to
see if we can retain all of those if we
can't because the business can't afford
to do so there will be a regrettable
decision but it just puts into context
the crisis that we are facing today now
another point that the Union have made
to us is why is IAG going through with
the acquisition a very Roper that
doesn't look like the activity of a
cash-strapped business well first and
foremost I AG is not going through it's
the acquisition is done at an Iberia
level and I think it's important to
stress you know high AG is a single
economic entity with multiple operating
entities and when we talk about the cash
in the business we aggregate the cash
that is held by all of the individual
airlines
but if Liberia is to progress the deal
with Air Europa it will be because it's
in the best interest of Iberia and the
acquisition will be made by Iberia
not by British Airways British Airways
will not have any involvement in it
not a single penny of British Airways
money will go towards that acquisition
so each of the individual airlines have
cash balances they have their own
balloon receipts and it's the
responsibility of each of the management
teams to ensure that they're running the
business in an appropriate fashion so if
the Iberia
area Roper merger goes ahead it's not
going to in any way impact on the people
in British Airways
why hasn't ba thoughts taytay's in the
way that Lufthansa and air france-klm
have it's a great question but the
reality is state a does not be made
available in the UK so what British
Airways has done it has applied under
the CC FF the Bank of England scheme
where we've issued commercial paper that
the Bank of England have acquired we've
done so up to the maximum amount that's
available to British Airways which is
300 million pounds
we've availed of all other facilities
that we can in the UK but there is no
state guaranteed loan system in the UK
unlike other countries and there is no
appetite and you've heard the Chancellor
in many interviews make this clear you
know he doesn't have an appetite for
stepping in he insists that all
businesses must do what they can within
their own resources
first and foremost and it's only when
all of those resources and opportunity
and avenues have been existed exhausted
should companies go to look for state
aid so the system in the UK is
completely different in fact there is no
common system across Europe so we have
done everything that is within our power
to boost the cash balance of British
Airways we're exhausting every single
opportunity we can and if the UK
government like some other European
governments wants to make state
guaranteed loans available to business
and it gets sensible for us to do so I
can assure you we will apply for it now
obviously you were hoping to get more
flights airborne over the next few weeks
but the UK government's just introduced
this 14-day quarantine period for UK
arrivals how unhelpful was that
it's terrible I wrote to MPs last night
to say you know that this initiative has
in effect torpedoed our opportunity to
get flying in July we think it's
irrational
we think it's disproportionate and we
are giving consideration to a legal
challenge to this legislation
so we're reviewing that with the lawyers
later on today I suspect there are other
airlines who are doing so because it's
important to point out there was no
consultation with the industry prior to
enacting this legislation and we do
believe it is it can occur a rational
piece of legislation and briefly if you
would please Willie what progress you're
making on refunds for canceled flights
yeah we're doing everything possible and
I'm pleased to say that the staff who
are dealing with that are working flat
out to try and make sure that everybody
who's entitled to a refund gets it you
know I think we're well ahead of most
people in the industry and we will
continue to do so but we have committed
to our customers that if they're
entitled to a refund they will get done
refunds I really wash great talking to
you thanks very much free time good see
it okay thanks